in the last few minutes we've heard that  30 million people have now received  their first  covet 19 vaccine it's the ongoing  success rollout that's led to the  confirmation from government today  that there will be no changes to the  plan to ease lockdown  from tomorrow people will be allowed to  travel within the country  and two households can meet outside  including in gardens  while the risk of importing new cases  from the rest of europe's led the  government to impose coronavirus tests  on holiers  from after easter but for now the  culture secretary told us that the  success of the vaccine rollout means  that the government  can continue easing lockdown